[Music]
I'm the one
you know I'm not a guy that takes
psychedelics or shrooms or smokes weed
but if there's ever been a podcast where
you you may want to consider Rob today
would be it right because today we're
going to be talking about aliens we're
going to talk about omua mua we're going
to be talking about the part that I was
fascinated with last night I want to get
some of your thoughts the underground
base they'll say Antarctica a little bit
of Paul Schneider Admiral Richard Byrd
stuff that is just you know uh uh things
that uh interest me a little bit I know
this is your world you're the expert
here but uh let me properly introduce my
guest today here folks we have the great
Avi loib uh in the house he's an
israeli-american theoretical physicist
who works on astrophysics and cosmology
he is the Frank Baird Junior professor
of science at Harvard University he has
been the longest serving chair of
Harvard's Department of astronomy from
2011 to 2020 founding director of
Harvard's black hole in initiative since
2016 and the director of The Institute
for Theory and computation since 2007
within the Harvard Smithsonian Center
for astrophysics in June 2020 loav was
sworn in as a member of a president's
Council of advisors on Science and
Technology at the White House in
December of 2012 Time Magazine selected
low as one of the top 25 most
influential people in space
in 2015 he was appointed as a science
theory director for breakthrough
initiatives of the Breakthrough price
foundation and 2018 he suggested that
alien spacecraft may be in the solar
system using the anomalous behavior of
omua mua as an example and in 2023 he
claimed to have recovered material from
an Interstellar meteor that could be
evidence of an alien Starship claims
which were criticized by some experts as
Hasty and Sensational he's got a big
announcement to make in less than three
weeks and he's got a book Interstellar
the search for extraterrestrial life and
our future in the star Avi it's great to
have you on a podcast thanks for having
me you could have saved a lot of time if
you introduced me as a curious farm boy
I was born on a farm and I'm curious
about nature and I don't have any
footprint on social media by the way
also I should mention probably you know
that but your last name that David is
the line of King David and and that is a
very important bloodline because the
idea is that it leads to the Messiah and
according to Christianity it was Jesus
that will come back again according to
Judaism the Messiah should arrive in the
future didn't arrive yet
and you know the philosopher buber
Martin buber said why argue about it
both sides believe that the Messiah will
arrive in the future
when the Messiah arrives we can just ask
whether he arrived already and figure it
out and regarding the Messiah should say
you know the idea is that Humanity will
have a more prosperous and exciting
future when the Messiah arrives we tend
to think that the Messiah is from this
Earth
but the future of humanity could be much
better if
someone will visit us from another
planet that is much wiser than we are
and we can talk about it and you believe
in God
uh it depends what you mean by that okay
so what's your definition of God
a very Advanced technological
civilization because if they understand
how to unify quantum mechanics and
gravity they could create a baby
Universe in their laboratory it's
possible that the Big Bang started
in a laboratory with Scientists in white
coats deciding to create our universe
and in that sense they serve the purpose
of what we call God you know if we see a
burning bush like Moses so and we use
infrared cameras to monitor what it is
about and we realize that it's actually
a miracle you know that could tell us
that there is a superhuman entity out
there in religious texts I mean Moses
believed in God as a result but in the
context of science it could be a very
Advanced technological civilization we
can't understand their Technologies just
like a cave dweller coming to New York
City and all the Technologies out there
would look like a miracle so so what do
you believe in more do you believe more
that aliens exist or do you believe more
that Jesus uh you know is the Son of God
well here's the point the difference
between religion and science is that in
science everything is based on evidence
not on belief
and evidence is collected by instruments
not by people because if you see a car
accident there are multiple people
involved each of them reports something
different you can't rely on what people
say they have ulterior motives you know
even in the World Cup the Women's World
Cup recently the U.S team was kicked out
as a result of video cameras looking at
the ball during the penalty kick and
deciding that based on the data from
those video cameras indeed the ball
crossed the line and was a goal so what
I'm saying is FIFA realizes that you
can't rely on the players on the
audience you have to rely on instruments
that tell you what really happens and
that's the method of science rather than
people saying I believe the ball went
across the line no you need to look at
actual data to figure it out and in that
sense it's information that can be
shared by everyone that everyone would
agree to whereas beliefs could be
subjective that's the difference but
what I'm saying is in the future if we
see a much more advanced technological
civilization near us it would look like
an approximation to God because it would
produce Miracles that for us cannot be
understood because they represent
Technologies of the future it will give
us some sense of what our future might
be like but it would look like a miracle
and it will fill us with a sense of oh
just like in religion but based on
evidence collected by instruments that's
the distinction so so for you
um you said you're you're a curious kid
from a farm right right it's kind of
what you said but there's a lot of
things to be curious about right you can
be curious about you know military
history of you know leadership there's a
lot of things to be here you could have
gone being a theologian you know there's
a lot of topics why this topic how did
you get all obsessed about this because
it's the most important question
um if the there is a discovery of a
neighbor
in our Cosmic backyard
it would change everything for Humanity
it will be the biggest discovery that
Humanity ever made
the situation is similar to being in a
family that is isolated and you go out
to the backyard and you find a tennis
ball thrown by a neighbor that will
change everything if you come back to
your family and say we actually have a
neighbor because then your family
members might decide to close off the
curtains to maintain their privacy or
might decide to go out and speak to the
neighbor and they might actually learn
something new and for us finding a more
advanced technological civilians and
more intelligent than we are because
they spend more than one century we just
had one century of Science and
Technology
just think about it a century ago we
discovered quantum mechanics
the way we are speaking right now is all
based on quantum mechanics all these
electronic gadgets are quantum and we
just discovered it a century ago that's
nothing in Cosmic history so another
civilization could have had thousands of
years millions of years or even billions
of years of technological advance and
that you know would look like
a miracle to us because now we are
developing uh you know chat GPT and AI
that starts to look like an alien
intelligence to us but think about it
you know decades from now or centuries
from now it would be unrecognizable so
what I'm saying is we have an
opportunity to get a glimpse at our
future because others already went
through it and if they sent a package to
our doorstep before we send the package
to their doorstep which is definitely
the case we didn't have any Gadget
leaving the solar system so far
then we could learn from them it's an
opportunity it's not a threat many
people worry about the threat even
Stephen Hawking talk about it I see it
as an opportunity to learn because for
them we would be just like a colony of
ants on the pavement looking at the
biker passing by you know the biker
doesn't really care about those ants for
us it's an opportunity to learn how the
biker operates the bicycle you know and
moves so fast and so I I see that as a
an event I mean this discovery is an
event that will change the future of
humanity will inspire us to change our
priorities for example now we spend two
trillion dollars every year on Military
budgets which is basically you know
either trying to kill adversaries or
worried you know trying to protect
yourself from them and you know that's a
destructive activity it's not a sign of
intelligence because you know it's
derived from our history as animals
where we had limited resources and that
we were engaged in zero-sum games where
if someone gets food another does not
but if you think about it there is space
out there much more real estate
available to us than on the
two-dimensional surface of this rock
that we were born on and basically you
know it's a very abundant resource a
huge amount of space you know you can
learn from other civilizations that
preceded Us by billions of years there
is a lot to do out there and we don't
pay attention to it and the wake-up call
may come from figuring out that there
are gadgets arriving to a doorstep and
we should examine them and only over the
past decade I should say the reason I
got into it you know I was working on
black holes on how the universe started
the first Stars I was entrenched in the
standard you know studies of cosmology
in astronomy but then uh I over the past
decade the first objects from outside
the solar system were discovered because
we for the first time had instruments
that can see them it includes the U.S
government satellites that were not
available more than a decade ago and
also some survey telescopes of
astronomers and given the fact that the
first two objects that we recognize and
we can talk more about them the first
was actually a meteor from 2014 the
second was umuamua from 2017.
the first two appeared weird they didn't
look like rocks that we are familiar
with and in fact my colleagues in
Academia still insist you know like a
month ago there was a paper published in
the astrophysical journal saying that
the meteor should be a stone because
otherwise those astronomers cannot fit
the data from the US government with
their model for stones and it should be
a stone and therefore the US government
the U.S space command got it wrong the
speed of this object must be three times
smaller than reported and I call that
the Stone Age of science where
everything in the sky must be Stones
just you know and it's basically uh you
know diminishing the the opportunity to
learn something new
and so I use the discovery of these two
objects the meteor and
learning experiences
an opportunity for us to recalculate
where we are and study them in more
detail and I actually went to the
Pacific Ocean a couple of months ago we
can talk about it yeah I definitely want
to do the question I want to ask you is
the phone we're going to go through
meteor we're going to go through some of
these things so what do you think is
more important for us to explore you
know how in life we're always more uh
curious about studying presidents or
studying you know successful leaders or
athletes but we don't study ourselves
that much we're always about focus on
other people and in life ends you're
like who was that I don't know what was
I doing here I kind of wasted our life
studying other people exactly do you
think do you think it's more important
for us to study space or where we
currently live meaning you know I did a
survey yesterday I said what should we
Explore More the outer space or the
oceans 65 according to 20 470 votes said
the ocean 35 said outer space
we don't know the you know investigating
what's in our core the whole Richard E
Byrd you know the Admiral with the
hollow Earth what's inside is there and
is there living going on so why not
spend more time here why spend more time
on Space well we can do both in fact
what I did in the Pacific Ocean was to
use microscopes to figure out what's
outside the solar system we can talk
more about it it's a new method in
astronomy never attempted before because
this was this meteor was the first
recognized object bigger than half a
meter that came from outside the solar
system the first one and by finding the
relics from it at the bottom of the
Pacific Ocean we could study what lies
outside the solar system so it's not a
contradiction you can study both and in
fact the oceans are very good museums of
things that fell on Earth because not
much is happening at the bottom of the
ocean more than a mile deep and I should
say that it's about time for us to
change priorities because
we can have a better role model than our
politicians than our entertainers
and that would be a more advanced
extraterrestrial technological
civilization which would be a smarter
kid
on our block that we can learn from you
know both my daughters that are now uh
older and but when they were young uh
they were at home and they thought the
world centers on them until I took them
to the kindergarten on the first day
they had a psychological shock because
suddenly they saw a smarter kid
but the way I saw it is an opportunity
for them to evolve to develop to be
better and that's what we should do of
course there is a resistance because we
want to believe that we are at the
center of the universe that's what we
believe for thousands of years you see
that in religions
and you know until Copernicus and
Galileo realized that actually we are
not the Earth moves around the Sun uh
and of course Galileo was put in house
arrest because and today he would have
been canceled on social media because
the church and theologians did not want
him to be heard with this View
for political reasons they wanted people
to believe that they're really uh you
know being looked at by God and they are
at the center but we now know from space
missions that we would never reach Mars
if we believe that Mars moves around the
earth I mean we would never do that so
we know that the Earth is not at the
center we also know that humans you know
this human species started a few million
years ago on Earth which is just one
part in ten thousand of the age of the
universe so you just think about the
cosmic play we arrived
to the cosmic play at the end near the
end and we are not at the center of
stage
that means that the play is not about us
and we better seek other actors that
were around for longer time
to figure out what the play is about we
keep thinking that we are Central that
everyone looks at us no
in fact it's our duty to search for them
people say uh extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence you know
all my colleagues in Academia say that
but they are not seeking the evidence
that's the main point they are not
engaged in the search for packages that
arrive to us from other civilizations I
say extraordinary evidence requires
extraordinary funding you need to engage
in the search and we haven't done that
we've been looking for radio signals for
70 years it's just like waiting for a
phone call it all started with Enrico
for me asking where is everybody which
is very pretentious because if you think
about it's like staying at home and
saying I don't have a partner nobody is
standing next to me but to find a
partner you need to go to dating sites
you need to look through your windows
and you need to at least go out to the
backyard to see if there are any objects
that arrived from someone and we haven't
done that until the last decade so an
Elon Musk for example made a statement
recently where he said
you know I'm the space guy
I know
things about space and if we had
evidence for aliens I would know about
it well guess what Elon Musk knows about
you know the region around the orbit of
the Earth around the Sun okay that's
what he's focused on going to Mars and
so forth
this is one part in a quadrillion of the
size of the universe you know one part
in 10 to the 15. the situation is
similar to an ant
serving the head of a pin
and making a statement about the most
distant planet in the solar system
that's the range of scales that would be
a very presumptuous and
that's what I say about Elon Musk is a
very presumptuous and you think so yes
so so you're saying it's arrogant to
think one would know uh if there are
aliens out there or not yes I do think
without seeking the point is you know we
don't know what most of the matter in
the universe maybe maybe he knows maybe
maybe no he pretends that maybe aliens
use Twitter and they tweet you know
stuff out and we don't know about him
they've asked him to please not tell
anybody well these are probably illegal
aliens but
but but
we're talking different kind of aliens
yes yeah yes but what I'm saying is you
need to engage in the search before you
find something of value and people are
just talking without doing the the
search and moreover the search is being
ridiculed it's been there is a pushback
I went to the Pacific Ocean
and some of my colleagues say why waste
the money why waste the time you know
you have very little chance of finding
anything you're looking for tiny
droplets from the surface of the object
that melted off when it was exposed to
the immense heat from the fireball that
it generated in the atmosphere you know
across the region of 10 kilometers in
size a depth of two kilometers you have
no chance of finding it and I said sit
back and relax I'm not asking you to do
anything I'm doing the heavy lifting not
taking money from your dark matter
research
and just wait if I don't find anything
you can say I didn't expect you to find
anything
you know we don't know what most of the
matter in the universe is 83 percent of
it is called dark matter it's a
substance that we've never witnessed in
the solar system so we clearly know that
what we find in the solar system does
not represent the universe 83 percent of
the matter is something else if these
astronomers that claim that the first
meteor must have been Stone if they saw
the data on dark matter they would stay
they would say that data must be wrong
because I cannot fit it with stones and
I would say of course you can't fit it
with stones because it's something else
and the same is true about this meteor
they cannot fit it with a stone because
it could be
a voyager-like spacecraft that has
material strength much larger than all
the space rocks previously identified by
NASA over the past decade 272 of them we
did the calculation based on the data
from the US government the U.S space
command we found that it's tougher than
all rocks including iron meteorites and
moreover we calculated that its speed
outside the solar system it was not
bound to the Sun and its speed was
higher than 95 percent of all the stars
in the vicinity of the solar system
so it could have been a spacecraft and
claiming that you cannot fit it with a
stone and therefore the U.S space
command which by the way is the
organization that receives more funding
than NASA and is supposed to tell the
president of the United States if there
are ballistic missiles aiming at us the
astronomers just a month ago claim they
don't know what they're talking about by
a factor of three which is huge they
would report to Mexico about a ballistic
missile when it's going to hit
Washington DC if that was correct if
they can't figure it out within a factor
of three and I say now we can sleep
better at night because I went to the
Pacific Ocean Guided by the data from
the U.S space command and I found
something okay so despite the ridicule
by these astronomers
I confirmed that indeed the US
government knows what it's talking about
and I sleep better at night otherwise I
would worry about ballistic missiles so
you know you've seen the Bob Lazar
documentary uh uh I'm sure you have I
don't know if you have or not uh so on
The Bob Lazar documentary one of the
things when you watch him uh I'm
watching for a sensationalism right like
you know somebody that's very much about
selling and all this stuff I don't get
any vibe from him that he's selling
anything that doesn't mean that he's
right it doesn't mean he's right or
wrong I just don't get a feeling from
him that he's selling anything and then
you see where he's like no I was there
you know he worked at I think it's S4 I
don't know which one it was right
outside of a Area 51 not in Area 51 he
thought he worked outside of Area 51 and
he said he saw stuff and he worked on
things and
he you know whether he build them up or
took him apart and put them back up
together he felt an obligation that the
people needed to know and he's always
been afraid to do interviews by himself
he wants to have somebody else there he
doesn't at first he didn't want to be on
camera it was just a basic interview
that he did and he's got a bunch of
criticism his entire life he doesn't
want to talk about it they did another
documentary 2019.
why do you think if we as taxpayers if
we fund NASA if we fund all of these
projects that they're spending money on
right it's our money like if I gave
money to you know if you gave me money
for me to go build a house it's easy for
you have the responsibility to ask me
Pat where are we at with this project
what's left before the house has built
how many bedrooms are we done with the
pool are we done with the and I have to
give you the report back because it's
your money to me right this relationship
is honest but why do you think the
relationship where we fund these things
with our money yet they keep secret of
the things that we funded do you think
do you think it's the right thing to do
for the government to keep those things
away from us to say you guys are too
low-level people to know this kind of
stuff it's not good for you let us kind
of know about it because if you knew
it's a danger to society or do you think
we are obligated to know we are
obligated to know I think it's
completely inappropriate if you go out
and find evidence for a neighbor you
have to tell your family members about
it and you know it's scientific
knowledge that should be shared by All
Humans has nothing to do with National
Security because if this whatever
material came from thousands of light
years away you know it may have taken
millions or billions of years for it to
arrive here we were not around at that
time there were no Nations the way we
split the land on this rock that we call
Earth is completely relevant now you may
say okay well maybe the US government
wants to take advantage of some
knowledge that adversaries do not have
and in that case it might delegate you
know those materials to corporations and
then the corporations you know will have
an interest just like a psychiatrist
that has a patient the psychiatrist will
never solve the problem of the patient
why because once the problem is solved
the psychiatrist will not get paid
right so in the same way if a
corporation gets access to some
materials uh
they will never figure out exactly how
to use it or what as long as they get
paid by the Department of Defense and
that may be the relationship that has
been around for decades now I don't know
if that's the case or not the latest
Incarnation forget about Bob Lazar let's
think about the future David grush
testified in the House of
Representatives just a couple of weeks
ago and said that the US government has
programs for retrieval and reverse
engineering of alien spacecraft
that were collected
over the past few decades and the good
news is that he promised to give
Representatives Congress people
the names of contact people who were in
engaged in those programs he said that
he spoke with 40 of them
now it could be that this story is
fabricated we don't know because he
didn't have access to the evidence
himself
but now we have a way to resolve it
because these Congress people can go
down the rabbit hole reach those people
and we might learn more in the coming
months uh if within a year we don't hear
anything that means that it was probably
fabricated but there is a way moving
forward with Lazar there was no way for
us to figure it out now but with grash
given the information that hopefully he
provided the Congress the Congress we
can move forward and within a year
figure out I say I don't know if we will
learn about what lies outside the solar
system first from the bottom of the
Pacific Ocean or from politicians in
Washington DC but the sky is not
classified the oceans are not classified
therefore
we can just figure it out ourselves we
don't need the government to tell us you
know people ask the government to
disclose information the thing is it's
hidden behind the veil of National
Security the argument of the government
is some of this data
is a matter of National Security
therefore we keep it classified I say
keep it classified I don't care about it
as a scientist I can collect the
evidence the problem is until recently
scientists
or the Academia was ridiculing this
subject such that nobody actually took
it seriously enough to engage in a
research project and you know I'm the
head of the Galileo project
where we built actually a functioning
Observatory at Harvard University
monitoring the sky 24 7.
in the infrared Optical radio and audio
and analyzing the data with machine
learning software and this is the first
Observatory we plan to make multiple
copies of it put them in many locations
hopefully we'll have the funding we need
which is only tens of millions of
dollars to do this to get to the bottom
of these unidentified anomalous
phenomena that the Director of National
Intelligence reported to Congress about
two years ago that's when I established
the Galileo project and you know there
was a second report a year ago and there
is a new office in the Pentagon to look
into that and the point is the
government is not a scientific
organization so if there is something
from Beyond this Earth it should be
scientists that explore it where the
data is shared with the public we don't
have to ask the government who is
engaged in their day job in National
Security we don't have to ask them to
release anything because the sky is not
classified why don't you we figure it
out
got it so you're putting it on okay so
who has done a better job making
advancement on learning is it the
government is it universities or is it
private companies universities did not
engage in this subject until we
established the Galileo project
and now as part of the Galileo project
we went to the Pacific Ocean to retrieve
fragments of the first Interstellar
object we are having we are constructing
these observatories that will give us
data in the coming years
corporations were never into that unless
the Department of Defense authorized
them asked them gave them materials that
they found and by the way the government
is the first to notice something unusual
in the sky because that's their day job
to look for ballistic misses for
National Security threats for Espionage
you know they shut down the balloon from
China
so they have to monitor the sky and they
would be first to notice it astronomers
will not notice it because astronomers
focus on very distant sources at the
edge of the universe or our galaxy and
they look at a small portion of the sky
if if a bird flies overhead astronomers
ignore it so we had to build a new type
of Observatory never done before within
the Galileo project and now we can
duplicate it make more of it if we get
the funding we really need the 10 times
more funding we have just a few million
dollars do the three does private
universities and the government work
together or is it kind of like you know
how you see in movies you know PD is
trying to handle and an FBI comes in and
says don't worry about a step down we
got it from here you got it and they
kind of don't like each other right do
you guys work collectively together or
no it's all separate well the interest
from government the public interest this
office in the Pentagon was established
just a year ago so it's new and I had
visits to my home they didn't ask me to
go to Washington DC they came to my home
of members of that office to see what we
do in the Galileo project and I really
see the two efforts as complementary
because they are supposed to worry about
whether it's China or Russia that are
producing these gadgets that they cannot
identify in the sky I mean they identify
97 but there are a few percent of the
objects that they cannot figure out
that's according to the director of that
new office in the Pentagon and of course
if they belong to adversaries that's
their day job but if it's from outside
of this Earth that's my day job as a
scientist I want to figure out what it
means and so I'm looking for one in a
thousand one in a you know in a large
number of objects it's probably a mixed
bag a lot of them are balloons there are
balloons everywhere when you hear about
UFO reports or unidentified anomalous
phenomena you know most of them are
probably balloons because they are
correlated the number of reports is
clearly correlated with population
density so more people that are looking
at this guy the more reports you have
and most of them are just mundane things
so but scientifically we can figure out
whether there is a small minority of
those
which might be really unusual yeah were
you going to say something Tom not on
that point no okay so you know even John
podesta said in 2002 right it's time to
find out the truth really uh is that's
out there we ought to do it really
because it's right we ought to do it
quite frankly because the American
people can handle the truth and we ought
to do it because it's the law right even
exactly and it's the Civil obligation of
scientists you know if the government is
interested as we know now the Congress
is discussing it you know openly and the
public is extremely interested
two-thirds of Americans believe in
extraterrestrial intelligence two-thirds
that's more than the fraction that
believes in God the biblical God
so clearly there is a huge interest in
the public huge interesting government
right now I think you know there is no
way that this subject should not become
mainstream in science
the only place that is hostile to such
study
is Academia and you ask yourself how is
that possible because Academia is
supposed to be about blue sky
research you know about evidence so if
we hear about
anomalies about objects that we cannot
explain easily the anxiety should be
thrilled at the opportunity to learn
something new instead I can tell you
that when there was a colloquium about
the omuamua this strange object that was
discovered 2017 at Harvard when I left
the room a colleague of mine that worked
on rocks for decades he said
omuamua is so weird I wish it never
existed
that's exactly the opposite of what a
scientist should say a scientist should
say omomo is so weird let's study
objects like it in more detail so we can
figure it out the childhood curiosity we
lose it when we become the adults in the
room and that's very bad if Academia is
dominated by people pretending to be the
adults in the room what's weird about it
what's weird because that this question
no what's weird about omua MOA because
I've seen a bunch of different things
how it travels the speed how big it is
the size of Noah's Ark all the stuff you
read about what's weird about it right
so well first of all the reason I was
intrigued is because a decade before it
was discovered I wrote the first paper
that forecasted how many objects as big
as a football field should be observed
by this telescope in Hawaii
and we predicted nothing
not only nothing the chance is less than
a percent for it to see anything then it
was discovered because it came close to
Earth it was not discovered because it
was intestinal that was not the reason
it just came close to Earth within a
sixth of the Earth's sun separation and
they flagged it in Hawaii as a
near-earth object that is worth their
attention because the entire survey was
geared around finding objects that can
threaten
Humanity you know if they collide with
Earth there would be a huge Devastation
you know we know that dinosaurs died 66
million years ago we are smarter than
they are we have telescopes they didn't
look up and they died so humans have a
better future because we can alert
ourselves so there was this telescope
looking and then this object was found
that was a surprise to me we didn't
expect rocks based on what we know about
the solar system coming from other stars
so I said what is this and then there
you know the people who discovered
started reporting about unusual
properties of it
even in the first discovery paper it was
said that it's most likely flat in its
shape which is quite unusual and has a
very extreme shape because the amount of
sunlight reflected from it changed by a
factor of 10 as it was stumbling and
that's unusual at most you see a factor
of three when you have a elongated
object but here just think about about a
piece of paper tumbling in the wind and
the chance of it lining up with your
view such that you see just the thin uh
you know like razor thin edge of it it's
very small so most if you see a
variation by a factor of 10 in the area
projected on the sky that means it's
really thin it's very unusual and so
that was the first thing that was
unusual about it and then it was pushed
away from the Sun by some mysterious
Force which without showing any
commentary of operation no rocket effect
to push it the question is what was
pushing it and you know the only thing I
could think of given that there was no
gas or dust evaporated from him and you
really needed 10 percent of the mass of
the object to get evaporated in order to
push it by a strong enough Force the way
we see in comets there was clearly no
such gas that we are familiar with in
the case of comets
so I said maybe it's just the reflection
of sunlight which is pushing it and for
that the object had to be very thin like
a sail or like a surface of a spaceship
that was ripped apart and you just see
the surface being pushed by reflecting
sunlight and amazingly
three years later in September 2020
there was another object discovered by
the same telescope in Hawaii called 2020
so it was also pushed by reflection
reflection of sunlight that was verified
and moreover had no commentary
evaporation and after a few weeks the
astronomers said oh this one is actually
a rocket booster
that NASA launched in 1966 it's just the
shell of
um of
a lunar Mission
and because of that it had a very thin
wall and a large surface area saying
this who's saying that that's what it is
oh the same astronomers that discovered
and the point is there was never a paper
written about it but here is an example
of a technological object showing the
same qualitative behavior of omuamua we
know it's technological because we
produced it
the question is who produced omuamua
so who did
I don't know because the astronomers
after you know had very limited data
collected I just said let's leave it on
the table it looked so weird let's leave
it on the table as a possibility that
it's
uh technological in origin and at first
I should say the paper that I submitted
for publication industrial physical
Journal was accepted within three days
for publication their free said yes this
possibility makes a lot of sense because
we realize the object is flat and it may
be a light sail and everyone was
supportive until a few days later where
I had a television cruise at the
doorstep of my home
you know asking me
do you think we are not alone and then I
flew to Germany that day to a conference
the in Berlin the falling walls and as I
when I arrived there right my inbox was
full of messages from Good Morning
America to all kind and there were they
arranged at that conference a special
room for all the reporters that wanted
to speak with me including an Italian
reporter who shouted from the back of
the room do you think that you're
Galileo and I said I'm not thinking I'm
anything I mean I'm just a farm boy I'm
just saying these objects this object
looks weird we should study objects like
it in the future it could be
technological that's all I said and then
once the media got a lot of attention of
this my colleagues changed Direction
they started to push back and as of now
they are attacking me personally there
was a New York Times article where you
can see some comments one of them says
you know
uh we are sick of Avi lobes
wild speculation and I say why are you
sick I I just I wish you will be healthy
and prosperous I I don't want you to be
sick
I am going after evidence I cannot go
after evidence regarding omuamua because
it's far away now we can't study it I I
discovered another object this meteor
from 2014 that the US government found
and it was Interstellar in origin the
U.S space command confirmed it in an
official letter to NASA at the 99.99
that it came from outside the solar
system so the U.S Department of Defense
came to my defense
and they took time out of their day job
and said for the benefit of science we
confirmed this
and as a result I organized an
expedition to go there to the meteor
path and collect any materials left from
it so I'm just trying to get as much
evidence as possible this is the
scientific method why would anyone be
sick of checking the evidence
the only way I can think of explaining
it is that those people who pretend to
be a scientist are actually opposed to
the method of science as revealing new
knowledge because they have a huge
investment in past knowledge they
interpret everything in the sky as rocks
and as a result if someone says oh maybe
it's not a rock they go crazy is it like
the risk of being wrong of what they've
had predisposition beliefs that they've
collectively bought into and they kind
of have a hard time stepping away from
it yeah but think about it it's so we
are talking about science where I'm
trying to collect evidence and people
are opposed and call it a wild
speculation this is not a it's a
possibility that I'm trying to figure
out by collecting evidence that's
exactly the scientific method I worked
in cosmology where we don't know the
dark matter and for you know 90 years we
haven't figured out what dark matter is
there were billions of dollars invested
in experiments the most recent is the
Large Hadron Collider that looked for
supersymmetry the Dark Matter may be
some particle with the new symmetry of
nature everyone said yeah that should be
it and 10 billion dollars were put in
the Large Hadron Collider part of the
mainstream of physics
and we looked for it we didn't find it
nobody says that was a wild speculation
it was a mistake to invest 10 billion
dollars in the Large Hadron Collider
because that's the way science is done
10 billion dollars in there exactly we
haven't found the Dark Matter yet
I say that is the way science is done
you have an idea about what the dark
matter is you go and search for it it
costs money if you say it's an
extraordinary claim therefore you know I
don't want to engage in it because it
needs extraordinary evidence nobody said
that about super symmetry that it's an
extraord why because there was a
contingency of people saying oh that's
very natural let's go and people got
Awards I can tell you a story I went
um to breakfast uh half a year ago where
I sat next to a string theorist a very
accomplished one and that is celebrated
as the frontiers of physics even though
they work on extra Dimensions that we
don't have any experimental evidence for
for several decades these people the
theoretical physics Community is working
on ideas related to Dimensions beyond
the three that we are familiar with but
there is no evidence for it nobody says
that's a wild speculation I'm sick of it
nobody says that people say okay well
that's mathematical gymnastics it's
beautiful to see we might find it in a
century from now and they celebrated you
know Neil deGrasse Tyson Brian Greene
they all say it's the frontier of
physics even though physics is supposed
to be guided by experimental evidence
but there is this whole community of
mainstream physicists working on
something that was never tested
experimentally and doesn't have a chance
of being tested In Our Lifetime and they
don't have any problem with that that's
perfectly fine but my point is that at
the same time that this happens in the
mainstream of of physics there is
pushback and ridicule
in studying looking for evidence of real
things that we observe in the sky
trying to figure them out which is the
tradition of physics Guided by anomalies
let's figure them out if we find that we
have a simple explanation by collecting
the evidence
we will move on forget about it but
let's collect the evidence if for
90 years we will invest billions of
dollars and not find anything we will be
exactly at the same point as dark matter
searches are right now but so far no
federal funding was given to the search
for objects scientific search for
objects that could be technological from
outside the solar system near Earth
because you have Thinking by committees
Committees of mainstream scientists who
are engaged for decades in arguing that
everything in the sky is rocks
everything is Stones the Stone Age of
science
you keep going back to that uh uh Tom
were you going to say something yeah
there's there's two things that you're
pointing out here
um and the the first is okay what does
this dark matter so meteor comes down
here something comes through the sky
let's call it it meteor and you say hey
people just keep saying it's rocks so
you have the substance so the first
thing is you want to have more research
on these substances dark matter you went
to the Pacific Ocean you found some of
them and you found particulates okay so
that's one side
there are shooting stars things landing
on them in on the planet all the time
from space and it could be metals that
we just don't know yet right you know
you know a new entry to the uh table of
table of elements in this dark matter
that's what you're trying to figure out
well I should say most of the objects
that collide with Earth
are just rocks left over from the
construction
of the planets in the solar system so
they are just rocks that were left
behind sure but you're saying this part
this one is dark matter is different
it's a metal it's different it's not no
no the dark metal we don't know what it
is but the meteor that we saw I mean the
dark matter is not visible it doesn't
interact with light we cannot really
figure it out for many decades what I'm
talking about is a meteor that could
have been a spacecraft think of it as
Voyager the the spacecraft that we
launched sure we put like with another
planet that's right 1977 Voyager one and
we put an image of a man and we put some
symbols on the side yeah but imagine it
colliding with a planet somewhere yeah
in a billion years it would look like a
meteor well we're talking about the same
thing Voyager in 1977 and then we put
the one up there with the two Gold
Records right yes yep and you know we
got messages back from space they said
send more Chuck Berry so the the
interesting thing that was about because
there was Chuck Berry song that was
actually on this so I'm waiting for the
first thing to be we need more I'm not
very proud of the music that was put on
by the way I I always like the most
recent music and I think we can do much
better if we were to send a golden
record right now well you know it's for
light years away anything we send now is
old when it gets there right so it's
[Music]
so number one let's you want to find out
could this have been Advanced Metal
Advanced spaceship what whatever it is
or particles because it could be
anything right the second part of this
is the the notion of these elements as
you pointed out I had read that 90 of
visual of just people
and you know space patrols and all these
other people that work for the
government are saying hey ninety percent
of what people say think is UFO is
ultimately explainable by something it
could be a balloon could be whatever and
you're saying 97 of the items people
think they see they're just three
percent that needs this investigation of
research so we're on the same path there
that the majority of what people see is
natural but there's this little subset
out there and of that subset and so I
want your opinion on there are five
observables that everybody seems to
agree with
that are confusing to us one
anti-gravity activity
two sudden and instantaneous propulsion
three Hypersonic without heat Vapor or
sonic booms right so there's no natural
physics occurring with the Hypersonic
speed low observability the closer we
get to it we don't get to see it because
it Maneuvers away or something Pilots
are saying that and then finally
transmedium that it dives into the ocean
or it's even dived into Earth without
any visible disruption it just moves
mediums
what do you think about that part of it
because I understand hey these particles
I'll call them Metals the dark matter
these Metals you want to know what they
are they could be a spaceship they could
be whatever but please don't call them
rocks because they think it's something
else that's your first point what do you
think about the second part right with
these observables like of
but they saw in Hawaii
well two things when you consider
objects
flying in between stars there are two
types of objects one would be space
trash
just like Plastics collecting in the
ocean sure now so that's what was there
it was confirmed that was part of a
booster from a rocket that had launched
decades ago going around in space even
finally getting back down even Voyager
will become Space trash because it will
exit the solar system in 10 000 years
okay that's the time it will take it to
leave the Earth Cloud which is at the
periphery the outskirts of the solar
system so in 10 000 years Voyager will
not be functional anymore it will be
trash we pollute Interstellar space with
trash and other civilizations could have
done that for billions of years the
point is these objects that are the
trash the Plastics in the ocean of space
they keep collecting over time because
uh they are bound by gravity to the
Milky Way they cannot Escape they move
too slowly so they keep accumulating and
you might find some of this trash in
your backyard this will not be
functional devices they will collide
with Earth and burn up as a meteor okay
so that's one type
now I'm getting to your point there is
another class of objects which is
functional okay that at least according
to military personnel they see objects
that they can't figure out which are
moving in strange ways the way you
described it going into water coming
into
these are of a different type these were
if they originated from outside of this
Earth they must have traveled the
distance and arrived here now why would
they go underwater one simple example is
water could be fuel the it could be the
nutrient of a technological Gadget
because if you break for example the
water molecule into oxygen and hydrogen
both oxygen and hydrogen can be used as
fuel okay so that could be one reason
but of course what we can imagine is
based on our knowledge of science right
now this may represent things that we
don't fully understand as I said before
it would be all inspiring for us to
figure it out what these Technologies
mean but the first thing to do is really
simple we don't need to guess what it is
what we need to do is verify that what
we are looking at is not familiar
objects it's not Birds it's not drones
it's not balloons
you're talking about yeah no no but the
three percent is not
known it's uh unidentified what I'm
saying is let's identify let's get more
data let's more get more data on it such
that we can clearly see that it's a
technological object that has screws and
bolts and maybe even has a label made on
exoplanet Y and it has buttons on it
clearly technological not a bird not a
balloon and moreover it Maneuvers in
ways that our Technologies cannot
reproduce let's verify that now the
government says we have data to that
effect that's why the Congress is
discussing it I haven't seen that data
because it's classified that's what we
were discussing with Patrick and my
point is it should be made available to
scientists like myself so we can make
sense of it I think there should be a
partnership between scientists and
government on this issue and I strongly
advocate for the government to share
whatever information they have because
it's not a matter of National Security
if you can verify that it's not Chinese
or Russian and maybe they have that data
it's not publicly available for me to
look at I really want it but if the
government decides to keep hiding it I
have a plan B which is to collect the
data myself so your questions are
excellent but we I think at first just
need to make sure that these objects are
not familiar that they have a nature
that is completely beyond what we know
here on Earth they might be packages
that arrive to our doorstep from a
sender if we read the the postal address
of the sender we will realize that it's
actually from Beyond the solar system so
okay you're an author you're a deep
thinker you're a professor what do you
suspect of of those observables because
I didn't make this list of observables
up this is the list that everybody looks
at when they talk about what what pilots
that are not intoxicated you're and
you're talking about people that are
credible Witnesses Pilots commercial
pilots people like this scientists on
Earth of that three percent when you see
these things what do you suspect today
because if I ask you what you know
you're going to tell me
take me down the same path you just did
there which I respect because it's a
path of scientific suspicion scientific
hypothesis H1 h0 and you got to get
there and figure out where you are I get
it what do you suspect about the things
that seem to defy Earthly physics well
it doesn't defy because it's all based
on people telling you something if I had
the data the raw data that substantiates
all of these claims I could tell you
what it means but some people we have
some data you've no tracking no there is
no there is no convincing data that I'm
aware of that Beyond any reasonable
doubt shows that it's something Beyond
of this Earth about unidentified
anomalous phenomena and moreover the
data that is available was collected by
cameras that were in cockpits that were
jittery we don't have full control over
the instruments that collected that data
what I want is high quality data and if
the government has it perhaps they have
it from satellites as you know the
former Director of National Intelligence
hinted Radcliffe he said uh that there
is satellite data we haven't seen it
it's possible that such data exists
because the head of NASA Bill Nelson
said publicly or on CNN a couple of
years ago he said that the hair in the
back of his neck stood up when as a
senator he saw this data I don't know
how frequently the hair in the back of
Bill Nelson's neck stands up I don't
know that because he's not a friend of
mine but that's a very interesting
statement it means scientists should
engage and that's what Bill Nelson
wanted and a day after he said that I
wrote to NASA and said that I'm happy to
make their boss
happy I'm happy to help them
I sent a white paper they established a
study as a result of that white paper
they've never come back to me in the
meantime I established a Galileo project
because I don't have the patience for
government the bureaucracy of government
to resolve this matter you know as a kid
you want to figure out the answer
yourself not to rely on the you know the
adults in the room that's the most
devastating experience I had was the
question though what as a kid what
question like this whole journey started
with wanting to know what like did you
want to know if aliens existed no
I was interested in philosophical
questions I was interested in even
simple questions and when I raised it at
the dinner table the adults in the room
when I was a kid would pretend that they
know much more or if they didn't know
they would dismiss the question
so I said to myself that's very
frustrating they're fooling me I want to
figure it out myself and the best way to
figure it out is through science okay
but what I realized now when I'm 61
years old after Decades of scientific
work
that the experience is very similar with
Scientists with colleagues who have a
Prejudice think they know the answer in
advance are not seeking the evidence to
guide them and resist change that's the
worst because it basically diminishes
Innovation science is all about
Innovation new knowledge and you should
be intrigued you should be curious about
that instead what you see is people
worrying about their stature you know
showing off as if they are smarter Trend
with Scientists it seems to be a trend
with Scientists fearing being wrong and
eventually feeling like they're God
exactly is that common like they they
think they're God or they want to be God
they want to look like it so I'll give
you an example I know a couple guys a
guy named Tony I don't know if you know
who he is but go ahead you were saying
yeah thank goodness
go ahead you were saying so yeah so when
I went to the Expedition I wrote 43
diary reports yeah on medium.com
and they received instantly millions of
readers they were translated to Spanish
when I came back from the Expedition my
colleagues many of them
basically pushed back and said how dare
you write about the scientific project
before you published a scientific paper
with your results and I said well look
the reason that the public thinks about
science as an occupation of the elite is
because it's a self-inflicted wound the
scientists say we need to tell the
public what the answer is in press
conferences after we know it for sure we
will never expose the uncertainties the
mistakes we make along the way but I say
let's show the public that doing science
is like a detective story you know you
don't know the answer you make mistakes
but once the evidence is clear enough
The public's the public believes you
because the public loves detective
stories and by the way I had emails from
fans during the Expedition saying one of
them had a stroke a few weeks earlier
said watching the scientific process the
way you describe it while making
mistakes trying to figure it out gave me
a meaning to my life and you know that's
very moving I connect to the public
because I don't regard myself as any
different than the public you know I I
had a plumber come to my home to fix the
sewer we had it clogged and I went with
the plumber to the basement and I
realized oh I never thought about the
fact that the water in my home goes to
some place outside the home and we
figured out it's basically three routes
that clog it and that gave me an insight
about black holes I then thought okay
where is the matter that goes into a
black hole where does it go if it's
clogged near the center the matter will
collect there and get very high density
but eventually make an object there you
know that's a possibility we don't know
what happens to it it may also go to
another universe but I came to think
about it because my sewer was clogged
and I spent hours with the plumber to me
hours with a plumber are not less
valuable than ours with my colleague 6.
I don't see myself as any different than
any other person I just want to figure
out the reality that we live in why
because we need to adapt to it if we are
not at the center of the universe and we
want to send Rockets to Mars you know we
need to know that so I just figured you
out so as a kid your dream was to be a
plumber that's what it is and is that
the feeling you're also no no I had Plan
B yeah I didn't work out you're going to
be a plumber no I went to Harvard
um as a junior faculty and it was not
clear at all that I will get tenure
because the previous person who got
tenure from within you know that
happened 15 years earlier so I had no
concerns about it because I had Plan B
of going back to the farm that was
really it didn't work out for you if it
doesn't I you know I don't see
science or Academia as Superior in any
way to working on the farm yeah it's
just that I'm curious so I think science
can help me figure out things yeah so so
let me go through my basic selfish
questions that I have okay we got 45
minutes left I just want to go through
some of these things
is the moon landing real
yes you think it is yeah how certain are
you because we have moon rocks you know
they brought back things
because we have moon rocks yeah that's
the evidence material evidence is beyond
the doubt when you have it and by the
way the moon was a piece that was ripped
off Earth as a result of a collision of
a bigger object a long time did you know
that the Earth had eight hours in a day
uh when it started it was spinning
really fast and once the moon was
chipped off
the spin of the Earth was slowed down so
now we have 24 hours imagine that we had
eight hours in a day you know we
wouldn't get much sleep right now we'd
be sleeping two three hours a day so so
you're certain we landed on the moon
have you ever looked at uh is it Bart's
uh what's his last name cebro is that
his name I think it's Bart if you look
him up
um
let me let me properly touch yeah Bart
sieber you ever heard his uh uh uh no uh
assumptions on what happened that the
the whole thing was fake they shot it
the shoe you know footprint doesn't
match the bottom of the foot you know
the shoe that they had on you don't yeah
no because there are micro meteorites
that impact the moon all the time it has
no atmosphere so everything on the
surface keeps changing
and by the way just to let you know on
Mars Suppose there was a city on Mars
yeah like you know like Fort Lauderdale
suppose it existed a few billion years
ago when Mars had an atmosphere oceans
and so forth there was a Ford Road
there would be no high-rise standing
today because every square kilometer was
bombarded by the equivalent of 20
Hiroshima atomic bombs
as a result of
impacts by asteroids by
so over billions of years anything on
the surface is demolished even high
rises would not survive on Mars for two
billion years nothing everything will
think about 20
Hiroshima bombs for every square
kilometer
so then the question becomes the
following okay so do you think
technology has advanced or technology
has you know gotten worse in the last 60
years oh definitely so how is it that if
we landed on the moon in 1960 what is it
69 I believe we landed on the moon
how come we haven't gone back that's
politics for you that's the focus on
what happens on Earth instead of looking
up
politicians I mean that you have to
realize JFK announced the moon mission
because of Russia the competition and it
was a political act okay once we
demonstrated the U.S demonstrated it can
do better than Russia then priorities
changed okay and you so the space
exploration priorities change from the
US government yeah I mean space
exploration if you think about it was
motivated either by national pride or
nowadays with the U.S space force it's
also National Security because there is
espionage from space looking down on
Earth
uh I mean the Chinese want to go to the
other side of the moon for national
pride but they also have national
security reasons to go to space the
third component that Elon Musk Pioneer
then is now dominating is uh you know
Revenue
making money out of space which you know
he puts a lot of communication
satellites out there makes a lot of
money that funds SpaceX you have these
three but that's the these are the wrong
motivations the actual motivation to go
to space is curiosity you want to figure
out what is out there and we are not
doing it and you know that's unfortunate
because I think it's a sign of
intelligence to send things out of space
not because you make money out of it not
because you are bragging showing off
relative to other nations
and not because of National City I have
a hard time believing that and I'll tell
you why because on the competition side
right they said China wants to go to the
other side of the moon right so okay U.S
politics totally understand but it's not
like we're the only ones that's
interested in the moon if it's so if
it's something that's doable that
technology from 69 pulled it off you
mean to tell me out of you know however
many countries that we have that aspire
to go there how come none of them how
come they're not doing it well it was
not a priority politically but the
Artemis program of NASA illustrates and
that was you know started
more than four years ago that
shows you that we can do better than we
did in the 60s now it's just a question
of politics do you see that as a way of
showing off relative to other nations
and only recently because of the race
with China I mean Russia is now even
though Putin just launched a spacecraft
you know
as a matter of National Prayer
national pride
because of China now we are trying to go
back to the moon and and there are also
commercial benefits to going back to the
moon so it's all politics it's not
curiosity driven we think it's all
politics yes I have a hard time with
that one I have a hard time with that
one being all politics let me go to
another one too by the way uh science is
better than politics I should that's I
want the challenges with Scientists
sometimes scientists sometimes
especially those scientists who don't
believe in God my experiences secretly
they aspire to one day be God I don't
know why like and I'm not saying all of
them some of them they have this
tendency of wanting to
um and maybe maybe it's because they're
they're they're spending so much time
into their studies and they talk to
others that are not at their levels of
intelligence that eventually they start
thinking I know more than you do just
listen to me trust me everything's going
to be okay it's very bad the practice
and the breaking news is that all of
them die
that's the breaking news yeah so UFO
sightings why do UFO sightings based on
you know what you read about tend to
increase during times of War you know oh
that's very simple because there are
lots of things flying in the air you
know there were astronomers in Ukraine
that reported about seeing dark objects
at distance of maybe 10 miles uh that
are the size of 10 meters and they're
moving at 15 kilometers per second like
10 miles per second not per hour per
second and that's faster than the Escape
speed from the earth okay they were
reporting about it they got it wrong the
distance was I think wrong and because
they would not be dark such objects
moving so fast would create a fireball
like a meteor so if you bring the
distance down by a factor of 10 or 100
you end up with perhaps artillery shells
perhaps bullets perhaps even
flies you know passing in front of their
camera
there are many more flying things in a
battlefield and that's why you get
confused so that's what I think is the
reason you might be extremely paranoid I
want to be extremely paranoid I want
your feedback on this so like this
article here says Ukraine's Astra
astronomers say there are tons of UFOs
over Kiev right okay right so to me you
know if if let's let's paint the
government to be who we think it is
right they think you don't have to know
everything they think they know what's
best they think it's better you not know
all the stuff about aliens okay so
there's two positioning here one is when
you read about Richard Byrd Admiral
Richard bird when he goes to Antarctica
and these two you know whatever you want
to call it take control the plane and
they land and they say look Our concern
is right now uh you know too many
Americans are humans are playing with
fire with the nuclear bomb and all this
other stuff this is a concern of ours
what are you guys doing on the other
side right is what he's talking about so
the concern is they want to prevent one
argument is they want to prevent from
war taking place because some of them
live here they live in the crust or they
live on the hollow side of Earth the
other part for me is which is a paranoid
way of thinking about it is when there's
war going on and there's a lot of issues
going on politically the best way to
distract people is say hey look I just
saw an alien while over here I'm robbing
you or I'm taking stuff away from you so
this is also a great tactic to distract
people and start focused on Aliens which
of those two do you think is more
credible oh the second but I I do think
that I have a problem with helicopter
parenting okay I don't think the aliens
are helicopter parenting us that's
unlikely because we are not that
important we're not their kids uh at
most they can just ignore us you know
um
but they started the journey to Earth
before humans existed on Earth they
didn't have us in mind we are not that
significant we keep thinking that
everything is centered on us you know
when you go out to a date you keep
thinking oh you are special that
everyone but then you realize after a
time that you know you're not that
special okay and that's what I think we
our starting point should be we it's a
sign of arrogance of us to think there
is nobody out there and if there is
someone out there they're really trying
to fix something here on Earth to help
us
you know I don't believe in uh
helicopter parenting I believe in
gadgets that may have been sent in our
Direction possibly with artificial
intelligence but they pursue their goals
okay and we need to figure out what
their goals are rather than assuming
that it's about us we are not that
significant let's be modest the cosmic
play is not about us so you think the
UFO citing increase could be a
distraction from the government working
on other things like yeah for example
the Ukrainian astronomers were able to
identify the distance to one object that
was very high you know like tens of
kilometers and that happens to be a
satellite and probably a satellite that
monitors what happens in the battlefield
so obviously there are lots of drones
there are lots of
satellites looking over this battlefield
that many of us are not aware of you
know the US government operates of
course intelligence operations around
this battlefield to help the Ukrainian
people you know that I'm sure is the
case so the ukrainians are not really
aware you know citizens or even the
military probably is not aware of
everything going on and they would see
things and of course some people might
say it's a UFO but it's really it's not
an unidentified object it's an object
that some people in Washington DC know
exactly what it is because you know they
operate it got it okay so it's a sign of
a maybe a distraction okay how much have
you studied Richard Byrd Admiral Byrd I
didn't study yeah so you don't know what
his theories are that there's a
potentially underground you know
Antarctica people living in the hollow
space but the inner side of Earth it's
possible but let's look for the evidence
if he were to show conclusive evidence
for that I would pay pay a lot of
attention to it but I cannot just Chase
every possibility what I'm chasing is
objects that we have good data on as an
astronomer you know um
the first one reported and then the
meteor was another one found by the US
government I went out to collect the
materials and by the way we didn't speak
about that but we have analyzed these
materials I cannot tell you the details
it will be they will be summarized in a
scientific paper coming out in a few
weeks
but they are very exciting they're very
exciting yeah got it so you you don't
have any interest in what we hear about
Antarctica no that there's limitations
until someone shows me evidence once
again the same with gracious story it
could be exciting if it's substantiated
by some materials that corporations or
the Department of Defense holds if there
is evidence for that if I speak to
people that saw it and can
corroborate that these reports then I
would have more faith that they are real
otherwise people can say anything you
know a lot of people say that they are
Napoleon
and when you ask them for their ID they
cannot prove that
they cannot prove that so
but but also at the same time if you
take that side if we haven't explored 95
of our oceans and you hear that number
being thrown around by a lot of
different people 95 percent and we don't
really know what's underneath us you
know some say uh uh according you know
uh Jesus what did Jesus say about uh the
devil what happens where hell and and
Satan is uh we talked about this earlier
about
you gave scripture Tom earlier about
yeah yeah in Christian scripture you
know
um the Old Testament uh the Jews talked
about sheol the the concept of hell and
the physical location of the devil's
residence and the fires and in the New
Testament there are references to hell
was you know Middle Earth Below Earth
and so it's it's there in religious and
religious texts that they talk about
these these presences could this be what
could these references are it could be
there is a lot of unknown I should say
the oceans are one and of course the
environment of Earth is another we
haven't monitored them in great detail
the fact that we found the first
Interstellar object just over the past
decade tells you we haven't explored you
know we found an object as big as a
football field we we cannot see objects
you know like emitter in size from the
reflection of sunlight using existing
telescope we're ignorant that's my whole
point that we should be modest approach
this with a sense of humility and by the
way religion advocates for humility
because there is a greater power out
there
I think scientists need this dose of
humility because we are on the path if
we were to search for things from other
civilizations we will be on the path to
all inspiring experiences things that
will put us at all and that's similar to
what religious people
experience except it's based on evidence
what do you think is easier to explore
what's in Earth crust underneath us
Ocean or space we should do both no
what's easier dog easier the oceans
definitely so why are we not doing that
though why are we not exploring where
we're living why are we so concerned
about other people's lives not our own
place because we are distracted by you
know things that are commonplace like
fighting for territories you know uh the
state of the economy the next election
you know there are lots of things that
can distract us we are having parties
we are just not focusing on what can
really change us I think that's okay
though I I don't think I think war is
going to keep happening I think people
trying to take care of the economy we
need those people I think military we
need military I think doctors we need
doctors but I'm talking more from you
from you because you guys you chose this
uh a career path I did not I chose a
completely different career path so my
job is to be a professional in my career
path whatever it was business insurance
Finance Investments that's what I have
to study right but I'm talking more from
folks who are explorers you know from
the world of wanting to know what's in
space why why not spend more time
finding out where we're living I
completely agree with you and that's why
I work 24 7. on this topic to bring new
knowledge and that's my duty I hope to
make you proud but at the same time I
face a lot of pushback from my
colleagues for doing that just trying to
collect the evidence and that shows you
that something is wrong in Academia in
science right now where everything has
to conform to what we already know and
people are less engaged in studying
anomalies things that do not pretty much
line up with rocks in the Sky What's
this here Rob just pulled up
is that you that doesn't look like you
no this is a picture of me but this
article is not um reporting anything uh
real because um we had the corporate
cooperation with the PNG government when
we went there and we actually are
collaborating with the University of
Technology at Papua New Guinea and some
people that were not in the loop said oh
you took this material by the way it's
completely outside the territorial
Waters of Papua New Guinea the what we
found are basically dust particles at
the depth of um you know more than a
mile a hundred kilometers away from
Papua New Guinea outside the territorial
Waters and some people claim oh you took
it but in scientific study of meteors
this is always the case where you go
places and you collect dust nobody cares
there is no commercial value to it there
is no biological value to it it falls
out of the rubric of international law
which deals mostly with commercial and
biological and you know that we didn't
do anything illegal in this operation we
just did the scientific project to study
dust you know less than a millimeter
sized particles at the bottom of the
ocean that came from by the way an
object oh that's very cool
kilometers deep and by the way the PNG
law says if you find anything even
within the territorial Waters it should
be returned to the senders well the
senders may be outside the solar system
let's find them but my point is uh this
was extremely difficult because you're
talking about particles that are less
than a millimeter less than the head of
a pin like a grain of sand sitting on
the ocean floor they melted off the
surface of the object when the fireball
exploded around it as a result of its
friction with air
and they rained down and sat on the
ocean floor across the region which is
more than seven miles in size and we
were in more than a mile deep the ocean
and we had to find them and what we did
is build a sled with magnets on both
sides and we basically skimmed the
surface of the ocean with these magnets
and collected all magnetic particles
fortunately
these materials had a lot of iron so it
was they were attracted to the magnets
after six days of crisscrossing that
region seven miles across that the US
government identified and that we
localized a little better with says
moment of data
we found mostly black powder that is
volcanic activity black particles uh and
then I wrote an essay on medium.com
saying where are these molten droplets
the spherols from the object and by the
way that shows you again I was
completely sincere that we are not
finding what we were looking for the
criticism for my colleagues is why are
you talking about science before we have
a paper well to show the public that
sometimes you don't find what you're
looking for we didn't find it then a day
later we filtered out the ash the
volcanic black powder using a mesh with
the size of a quarter of a millimeter
start finding those bigger particles put
them under a microscope and then saw
these metallic marbles beautiful
spherical things that are very distinct
from Sand and I remember that the
geologists on the team went down the
stairs from where we did the analysis
and called me I was the chief scientist
of this Expedition and said Avi we found
a sparrow and I went up rushing and I
hugged the person who found it through
the microscope and I said that's amazing
you know that's what we were looking for
and I knew from my experience in the
kitchen that if I find an ant there are
many more ants out there and surely
enough within hours we found more
marbles like that they were tiny my
daughter said could I get one for a
necklace and I said it's impossible to
thread those things they are less than a
millimeter in size we brought the sample
back to Harvard and I had an intern
during the summer Sophie Bertram who
went through the materials found
650 additional Swirls and now we're
analyzing them in the laboratory with
the mass spectrometers electron
microscopes so do you have any opinions
on Project Blue beam
what is it do you have do you know
anything about it or no no you've never
heard of it no Project Blue beam no okay
all right sounds good have you have you
studied at all uh the Dolce underground
base
no New Mexico and Colorado what happened
with the cows and it was documented and
the blood beans oh I heard about it you
know one the question the fundamental
question is could it could it be the
result of human-made things you know
actions could it be the result of
human-made things actions so okay so
maybe a better question to ask you is do
you actually believe we have proof that
aliens exist
no we have intriguing
uh evidence uh that leads us to the
possibility that we might have found or
that objects from produced by other
technological civilizations arrived near
Earth there is some intriguing evidence
uh but wait for our analysis of what we
found in the Pacific Ocean wait for more
data to be collected before we all say
we have the proof it's possible the US
government has materials or information
that is relevant but it's classified I
don't have access to it so what you see
is what you get when you speak with me
I'm not hiding anything I'm telling you
exactly the situation
with the US government we don't know
do you uh do you uh can you at all
speculate to say you think if I was to
speculate I would say aliens do exist or
oh yeah definitely I think it's arrogant
of us to believe that we are uh the most
intelligent species that ever lived
since the big bang that Albert Einstein
was the smartest scientist who lived for
the past 13.8 billion years that's
completely ridiculous actually because
you have tens of billions of stars like
the sun most of them formed billions of
years before the Sun so you know if you
just roll the dice of technological
civil it's very likely that you had many
more in our past many of those died
those civilizations are not around
anymore there were tragedies you know
the sun in a billion years forget about
global warming you know the situation
here in Florida is getting warm and warm
forget about what we do to our planet in
a billion years the sun will boil off
all the oceans on Earth
and other stars that formed more than a
billion years ago before the sun already
went through that so just think about an
Earth-like planet near one of these
stars that you know be a billion years
ago went through that and there must
have been a mass Exodus of you know uh
people out there or things like
creatures out there trying to leave the
planet you know people like Elon Musk
would make much more money because
everyone would want to go on a spaceship
and leave the planet it was the biggest
item in the news that the star is about
to extinct life on their Planet you know
the situation is like Mars Mars became a
desert once it lost its liquid water and
Ocean and the atmosphere so the same may
happen to Earth in a billion years and
what I'm saying is there were tragedies
in Cosmic histories a lot of
civilizations perished we are not aware
of that because we just came a few
million years ago we started looking at
the sky just over the past few centuries
you know a methodical way so you know we
are like an infant not aware of the
bigger perspective and we behave
irresponsibly because we don't really
try to seek that data let me ask you a
couple other questions here and then
we'll wrap up so you know how
um
Apple computer like you know every year
in a month of August or September my
Apple phone slows down every year okay
now some people say it's just your
phone's getting older you know you have
a lot of space you know whatever the
biggest phone you can terabyte whatever
it is I have that right because I got a
lot of stuff in their content in there
but then there is there's theories that
Apple intentionally does that for you to
feel like you have to upgrade your phone
right and I don't know if you believe
that or not but Apple has the ability to
do there's a possibility that they do
that so let's just put Apple uh uh as
the US government if they wanted to do
something like that they could because
they got they have that kind of power do
you see do you think we have the
technology right now
to create earthquakes and to change the
climate or create storms
definitely
okay now the next war is of course AI
okay so AI can be developed artificial
intelligence can be developed in the
private sector open AI you know chat GPT
and so forth or it can be developed
within government
the question is I mean you can put
restrictions on what corporations do
so far the regulations are not severe
you know from Washington DC there is not
enough attention to the risks from AI
but you can't put such restrictions on
government so My worry is once
regulations are enforced on the private
sector with respect to a that will not
prevent governments manipulating the
public through devices
that are hidden from view okay which may
already you know it's taking place you
know we just I mean there are lots of
ways by which on social media or
otherwise AI can assist governments in
manipulating the public in a much more
effective way than propaganda pamphlets
in previous decades I think that is the
biggest thing to watch for in politics
where AI will be used for the benefit of
factions of government that want to you
know produce a narrative so let's stay
on this so you believe the government
has technology to create earthquakes if
they wanted to oh definitely you're
saying definitely yeah because you can
explore the nuclear weapon and create an
earthquake no problem but to do it
without us knowing it was due to nuclear
to do it and say oh was a real life
earthquake that happened and deflect
yeah you can do that but then other
governments will notice it I mean a lot
of governments are what you know what
I'm asking
right I'm asking like if if if I wanted
to
hurt a community or city or state look
let's just say long term a state in
America a government or political side
is not a fan of can they create a
massive catastrophe in that area could
be Wind Fire earthquake could they do
that definitely but I mean like you
watched Oppenheimer probably of course
yeah yeah very good movie
it was a turning point because For the
First Time
politicians realize that physics is not
just academic you know people studying
the atomic nucleus initially it was
curiosity driven but Einstein said oh
mass is equivalent to energy and guess
what when you break a very heavy
nucleus like uranium it releases a lot
of energy Einstein realized that e equal
MC squared what he didn't realize is
that Oppenheimer who actually was a
colleague of Einstein later on at
Princeton
would develop
the Manhattan Project Lead it
such that this energy is being tapped
for political reasons and then Truman of
course used it and at the point in the
movie where they show the nuclear bombs
being delivered on a track outside of
Los Alamos
the general tells Oppenheimer
thank you very much from now on we take
care of that meaning whatever the
physicists develop this devastating
ability
was now harnessed by politics
and obviously that was the case now it
was used to end the war with Japan okay
as a tool uh it killed huge number of
people and from now on it's shaped after
that shaped international relations
everywhere
so at that point politicians said oh
physics could actually affect human
history politics and more money was
allocated to science in fact the
National Science Foundation was
established by Van verb Bush as a result
of he was portrayed in the film and much
more funding came to science because
politicians realized oh we can use it
and indeed you can use it and nowadays
it's you can use AI you can use and so
the point is
you know that the indeed governments are
interested in having more power
and science gives them more power
so to answer your question they
definitely will use it for me that's a
that's a very very powerful weapon if
you can fabricate
environmental
crisis and blame it on mother nature it
wasn't us it's an earthquake it wasn't
us it's a bad storm it wasn't us that's
the part that's that to me is as dark as
bio Warfare or a cyber warfare which we
haven't yet experienced these are things
as military you ought to be concerned
about because right if one can fabricate
an environmental catastrophe catastrophe
no one gets to blame no you can play
Angel and say let me come help you out
what do you guys need help with you know
I'm I live close to the Walden Pond
where Henry Thoreau went and said let's
leave behind the Industrial Revolution
Let's just
uh live with nature and I connect to
that when I see the devastating
consequences of us
modifying nature allowing governments to
do things that will never you know live
nature the way it used to be I really
miss that and to me going to space is
the only way to escape from the way we
ruin this Earth and
you know meet nature unspoiled by humans
so you know I was jogging on the ship
for the expedition to the Pacific Ocean
and I had a filming crew one out of 50
that approached me and wanted to be on
the ship and I selected one and the
director of that filming crew came to me
and said the Avi you're jogging because
I'm jogging every morning at Sunrise
including today uh and he asked me it
looks like you're running are you
running away from something or towards
something and I said both I'm running
away from some of my colleagues who have
strong opinions without seeking evidence
to support them and I'm running towards
a higher intelligence in interstellar
space
interesting at least you're running
though which is good the fact that
you're running is a good thing and I
also live on a diet of mostly dark
chocolate and really low carbs yes I
half of my calories are from Doctor have
you are you joking are you serious
serious
dark chocolate yeah when I get a wound
uh often you see yeah I got you I told
now now it's starting to make sense so
you are an alien this is oh you know
what um my wife 10 years ago said
you know it looks like you came from
somewhere else if they come and pick you
I want two things one that you leave the
car keys with me I know that you would
like to go with them and second make
sure that they don't ruin the loan when
they lift off now I spoke with her again
just a couple of months ago and that's a
sign of good marriage
she said I asked her would you join me
and she said yes that's good after how
many years
oh that's 20 years 20 years
congratulations 20 years I'm six years
behind you I think you just celebrated
20 or 21 years Tom some like that 21
yeah 21 years good amazing climate
change okay so your thoughts on climate
change your guy that's working at
Harvard okay when I went to Harvard for
a business program that they had not MBA
it was like a three-week program I had
owner president Management program
Harvard is an incredibly super left
organization super super left
organization I'll never forget like God
forbid you said something that was on
the conservative side or capitalism side
and you didn't mention social or any of
that stuff you are a bad person right I
should tell you when I jog in the
morning yeah I look at the yards of my
neighbors they have signs you can
imagine what they say yeah but clearly
the science always say
what you expect your neighbors to agree
with
and I say that is just virtue signaling
and the same is true for Harvard virtue
signaling you are showing off that you
are actually believing like everyone
else around you in the same things
I say a sign of Courage is to take your
sign bring it to a neighborhood that
doesn't agree with you right because
they're you are engaged in a dialogue
none of these people my neighbors would
be courageous and and colleagues at
Harvard would be courageous enough
to put those signs in a neighborhood
that disagrees with them well you know
that's a great project for someone to do
one take a Biden flag on a boat and go
to Palm Beach go boating that's one or
take a trump flag and put it outside of
a house in San Francisco that would be
actually a very interesting house a
project to see what happens but no
climate change what are your thoughts on
climate change how much of it is you
know it's the end of the world it's what
we have to worry about you know the next
12 years Greta thundberg AOC Al Gore
where do you stand with climate change
well you just look at history I mean the
Earth went through a lot of episodes
it's possible as the evidence shows that
indeed our actions modify the climate
Okay the question is you know we should
be practical and see how to moderate our
impact and
reverse the current trends and rather
than argue who is to blame and why this
happens which is pretty much the
political conversation
the question is let's be practical both
sides can agree that we need to do
something to mitigate any risks you know
and what should we do because you know
we don't want a lot of floods we don't
want the temperature to go too high we
should do things that moderate that
mitigate that forget about who is
responsible and why let's just find a
way to have a better future that's what
the conversation should be
that's it that's your opinion on it yeah
I think because right now there is
tribalism in in politics where each side
you know is closed in a bubble that
believes the same things and what we
need to do is work together towards a
better future okay it's about time for
us to you know when I was on the ship I
saw that all team members said we are
part of the same boat we are all in the
same boat let's work together for the
success of our mission you can think of
Earth is as our boat the boat of
humanity sailing through the ocean of
space
and you know we should work with each
other for a more prosperous future
rather than fight each other and make
statements about the other tribe you
know in Papua New Guinea where I visited
there are 850 languages
and I asked someone how is that possible
it's the highest concentration of
different languages in a geographical
site and I said why is that and I was
told that you know a group of people
decided that the tribe next to them must
be their enemy and as a result they need
to develop a completely different
language
so you ended up with 850 languages just
like the Tower of Babel and there is the
standard seal of belonging to a tribe
and hating anyone else as your enemy I
say forget about that it's not Zero Sum
games that we need to be engaging let's
work together so we can bring in a
better future for all of us
have you studied Werner von Braun
I know him yes what do you think about
him
well in a way he um you know founded the
U.S Space Program uh of course he had a
role also in Germany that is not
something to be proud of
it was a difficult political decision to
provide him with the authority but I
think the calculation was that he has
the expertise
and it proved itself you know it ended
up in a very successful space program
that the U.S had whether you should
engage with people who have the
knowledge but served
a foreign country that did atrocities
you know that's that's a moral judgment
question
I should say before the second world war
before the Holocaust the Germany had the
best scientists in the world
one thing mentioned in Oppenheimer is
Eisenberg
he was in charge Werner Eisenberg in
charge he was a physicist in charge of
the nuclear program of the Nazi regime
there is a possibility that they were
not successful because he didn't want to
provide Hitler with nuclear bombs we
don't know that for sure we know that it
was not successful like the Manhattan
Project
fundamental question is what did Werner
think you know privately
we don't know that and with respect to
the Space Program you know we all
benefit from it now
whether from Brown should have been
given that Authority in the U.S after
the war or not is a moral judgment that
is personal some column some call them
the father of space travel I think he
was part of the Nazi uh party himself he
was a member of it but have you seen
what he left on his Tombstone no can you
pull up his Tombstone Werner Von Braun
so father of space travel on his
Tombstone just go to images he puts
Psalm 19 1.
okay so this is a guide that studies
space travel and Psalm 19 1 is the
heavens declare the glory of God and a
firmament show it his handiwork
what do you think about a guy like that
the life he lived space Nazi to put
scripture on his tombstone
I have a problem actually appreciating
someone who belonged to the Nazi regime
because most of my father's family was
killed in the Holocaust they actually my
grandfather fought for Germany that's my
last name I'm called after him his name
was Albert Loeb Albert is equivalent to
Abraham which is shortened to Avi and he
fought in the first world war on the
German part against the French and there
was honored with a medal by Hitler when
Hitler came to power
and he had friends in the Nazi party who
warned him about what's about to happen
and then there was a gathering in the
village and in the Gathering someone
stood up and said you know the Jews are
using up all resources in our society
and my grandfather stood up and said how
dare you say that I fought on the German
front we were in the mud for two years
you know there were hundreds of
thousands of soldiers who died in that
battle the battle of Verdun
and you he said to the speaker you were
a communist at that time and now you are
preaching about Jews and that speaker
said Oh Mr Loeb I'm not talking about
you we all know that you are a patriot
I'm talking about the other Jews
at which point my grandfather left
everything he had in Germany
and came to Israel
which was Palestine at the time
and the rest of the family that had 65
members of my father
said oh we will live in the last train
you know we will leave Nazi Germany when
there is no hope anymore we believe in
Germany as a nation we are patriots
the last
train LED to Auschwitz
and they all died there I have a
difficulty given that history
in praising anyone that belonged to that
regime
it totally makes sense totally makes
sense to say that
um Dr avilo this has been amazing it's
been very interesting having you on here
if you don't mind taking a moment with
the audience uh Interstellar what's what
will the reader find in interstellar the
book first I should say the title of the
book Interstellar
relates to the content of the paper
about the findings of the expedition to
the Pacific Ocean that we had two months
ago so watch out
for both they will come out at the same
time it's already for sale the book
talks about the implications of
realizing
that we have a smarter kid on our Cosmic
block even if we don't have the evidence
yet
it will change us
and you know just knowing that you have
a neighbor that you can learn from
is life-changing because it's just like
finding a partner
you know the universe appears lonely to
us
if we find a partner it will not be as
lonely
we could converse with that partner we
could seek that partner we could benefit
from what the partner
learned before we came to exist it would
be a transformative event in Cosmic
history for our human history so let's
be open-minded let's seek that partner
let's seek a higher intelligence out
there and that's the message of my book
it will change Humanity it will change
our future let's find it I love it I
respect it Rob let's put the link below
to the book for people to be able to
order both in chat as well as in
description Rob do we have podcasts this
Thursday
we do it'll be a home team podcast on
Thursday we will do a home team podcast
on Thursday and the interview I did with
khabib will be coming out here soon so
stay out we're going to put that on PVD
podcast that one was mind-blowing it'll
come out soon take care everybody
bye-bye bye-bye
David here from the Italian pbd podcast
look once a year we host a conference
called The Vault conference it's our
Super Bowl where 3 000 entrepreneurs
CEOs executive sales people from around
the world come together to spend three
and a half days together from August
30th to September 2nd at the Diplomat
Resort in Miami to learn how to scale
their business how to identify their
next 5 10 15 moves who to recruit next
who to go raise their money from how to
raise Capital how to properly skill
culture retention higher fire all of
those things and much more and we do
that over a span of three and a half
days and the reason why it's a very
important season to attend a conference
like this the following reason today
there's three different types of people
they're scared they're those that are
content and the obsessed they're scared
they don't want to do anything because
they're worried about what's going to
happen in the economy they're going to
take a big hit the content they're
walking on saying life is pretty okay I
don't need to do anything else and then
there's the obsessed because they see a
massive opportunity today so imagine
spending three and a half days with
three thousand obsessed people that want
to grow on a seasonal life this imagine
how much you can run from just those
relationships and networks so on top of
the people that are going to be
attending at this event this is probably
the best lineup we'll ever have out of
all conference Tom Brady seven time
Champion I'll be interviewing him he'll
be at the Vault conference Mike Tyson
will gudara the gentleman who ran the
restaurant 11 Madison New York that went
from a regular restaurant to a one
Michelin star two Michelin star three
Michelin stars and eventually the number
one restaurant in the world he's going
to talk about how they treat their
customers so look if you've not
registered yeah this is my
recommendation to I never went to
conferences when I was coming up by
myself I always went with a spouse with
a business partner or running mate
because I only have a lens on what I see
every night afterwards we would sit
there and say what was your biggest
takeaway so get yourself your spouse
your partner your running mate
registered to come spend three and a
half days with us at the Diplomat Resort
in Miami from August 30th to September
2nd I will see you there
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]